[Music]
any of us are drawn to anime for
different reasons one is for the wuss
two is for the plot three is for the
animation and fourth the one that got us
hooked in anime is their powers growing
up many of us imitate the ultimate moves
of our favorite characters such as
Goku's gami hamiha Naruto's Rasengan and
ichigo's getsuga tenso to be honest the
list could go on for a very long time
and as we speak a lot of people are
being drawn to anime there are many
moments in anime where both the
protagonist and the antagonist show us
their ultimate powers and today we'll be
counting down the top 20 moments where
characters show us their ultimate Powers
starting off strong look up in the sky
it's a bird it's a plane no you're wrong
it's pain ready to destroy everything in
sight
this iconic moment was burnt in the
memories of those who watch this scene
as one of the best displays of ultimate
power moves I mean being able to destroy
a whole village by yourself is something
very few characters can achieve and pay
did it like it was a piece of cake
hovering over the hidden leaves
territory without anyone to stop him in
his tracks pay successfully brought
despair down to the citizens of the
Hidden Leaf Village that even the hul
gagi at the time was helpless in front
of P's absolute power sunade and the
other ninjas watched helplessly as pay
decimated their precious Village and
reduced it to nothing but Rubble pay's
almighty push proved to be a devastating
technique able to wipe out a whole
village with ease to this day that
Shinra tensei line in the Japanese dub
still sends shivers down our
spine now before we can continue let me
ask your little weeb heart for just a
moment of your time to present to you
the sponsor of this video raid Shadow
Legend raid Shadow Legends is a mobile
RPG game that has amazing Graphics has
over 750 unique Champions to collect
with billions of ways to customize them
awesome and scary bosses and best of all
it's free to play but that's not all do
you perhaps know the game kiss marry
kill so who are my picks first of all
for kiss I'd have to choose Madame sis
she's an epic champion from the dark
El's faction and I think you know why I
chose her right for Marry I'd have to
pick the legendary champion from the
shadowking faction you make go not only
do I want to marry her because she looks
like she came straight out of anime but
her skills are no joke and lastly the
one I would have to kill is the
miscreated monster I mean does he even
want to be here when he's miscreated
raid is giving out a legendary champion
it's so easy that you just have to log
in on seven different days between now
and October the 23rd to get Sun Wukong
The Monkey King so if this sounds right
up your alley then why not start now
using my link in the description or scan
my QR code to get insane bonuses we're
talking about an epic champion tiia from
the sacred order faction and other
useful things like energy refills skill
Toms and XP boosters once you're in the
game and destroying your opponents make
sure you come and find me under the name
Vin tube and if you're fast enough why
not join my clan next on the list is the
leader of the asakusa Village shinmon
benim Maru against an unfortunate
demon
when the white clads the main antagonist
of the fire for series decided that it
was a good idea to mess with Benny
maru's Turf they quickly realize how
badly they messed up with Benny maru's
abilities and Proficiency in combat he
may as well be a oneman army his control
over his powers is on a whole other
level he's honed his skills to near
Perfection and in his fight with the
demon the white Clans released in the
town of asakusa he Beed his fangs
against them and show just how powerful
he really is when his first attempt at
exercising the demon using I chop form 7
Sun wheel failed Benny Maru decided to
borrow conro technique the Crimson Moon
which ultimately finished the job not
only did Benny Maru erase the demon from
existence but with the Firepower Benny
Maru possesses he quite literally lit up
the night sky in a Sinister red color
the buildup of the story the
choreography of the fight the sound
effects and the visual effects all
worked together and created what's
possibly one of the best scenes in anime
when displaying overwhelming
strength
moving on we have oroi katsumi breaking
the sound barrier with his punch to try
and defeat
piol in the battle against pickle and
Gumi we all know Gumi lost but Gumi was
able to make pickle recognized him as a
strong and worthy opponent with gumi's
new technique the Mac punch didn't just
send pickle down to his knees but he
also sent pickle flying by countering
Pickle's assault using his new attack
quite ironic actually how a small man
can produce so much force that it
emulates the T-Rex's tail swing yeah you
heard me pickle saw his greatest Nemesis
during the Jurassic era in katsumi G
katsumi's Mac punch can travel an
astonishing speed of Max 78 or to be
precise
963149 km per hour now I don't know
about you but a punch at that speed
would probably blow your head off but
with the destructive power his punch
doesn't just hurt pickle it also
destroys gumi's hands and foot although
gumi's Mac punch can only be used once
as it destroys the user's body he proved
to everyone that was watching that he's
a force to be reckoned with in just a
few days he created a move that for a
short while was able to turn the fight
in his
favor
coming up next is the honored
one without a doubt Gojo's existence is
basically a walking flex but when he was
on the brink of death because of toi's
surprise attack he quickly demonstrated
his superiority unlike anyone else the
only mistake toi made when he thought he
finished the job was that he didn't make
sure it was done for good with that
opportunity at hand Gojo broke broke his
limits and came back stronger than ever
in their rematch Gojo makes it clear
that toi doesn't stand a chance against
him and completely dominates the
entirety of their fight and finishes the
job by unleashing the Gojo Clan's secret
technique the hollow purple ultimately
ending toi's life and blowing a hole
right through his body and anything
behind toi with that Gojo yet again
eliminated another person who could
rival his strength in his own verse it
was a quick attack that resulted in
toi's quick
death
following Gojo if you like moments where
anime characters go into rage mode then
you'll probably like gon's
entry when neito failed to keep her
promise to revive kite it prompted the
creation of their greatest enemy yet
adult gone consumed by rage gone made a
nen contract allowing him to sacrifice
all the nen he'll ever have in his life
to kill neito the result of gon's action
allowed his body to mature into where he
was at his prime a muscular adult with
immense power and N Aura in this form
gon was on the same level as maruem the
king of the chimira ants the way gon
brutally ended Neo's life using his bare
hands was a testament to the word
ultimate power itself and even neito
admitted that his fangs can reach the
king without a doubt gon's rage moment
and transformation is a feat that's
worthy to be on this
list
[Music]
next up if you're a veteran Anime
Watcher then you probably remember this
certain anime called haimo
IO because I assure you if you're a
DieHard fan of Sports Anime like slam
dunk I shield 21 and many more the scene
where IO unleashes his ultimate move the
Dempsey role for the first time against
ponchai will absolutely give you
Goosebumps for starters ippo didn't
actually know that the movements he
created already had a name and it was
the Dempsey role as IO told Gava that he
would end the match in a KO he was
oozing with confidence that it shocked
his coach it was io's first time using
the Dempsey rooll on a moving opponent
but his tenacity endurance strength and
perseverance made his attempt to success
against the ti boxer ponchai who proved
to be a difficult opponent for Io
ultimately in just two rounds IO was
able to seal the deal and win his
comeback match by unleashing his
Newfound technique and would win more
matches using the Dempsey roll making it
his signature move the impact was
amazing and even the animation was so
crisp so that's why it became
iconic hold your horses because we have
super Tangen topper Gan Lagan versus
anti-
spiral imagine summoning a Mech that
dwarves G and operating it I mean think
about it the size of the mech is
estimated for its height range to be at
least
348.50 billion light years to 10.45
trillion light years compared to the
observable universe which has a diameter
of 93 billion light years the stgl is at
least 3.7 to 112 times taller than the
observable universe now imagine yourself
a normal human operating a Mech that
huge and that's not all their enemy
anti-spiral grew the the same size as
them and both clashed with huge drills
with an estimated size of a 100
universes as they Clash drills they
created a Vortex that sucked in the
surrounding galaxies and I'm fairly
certain that as the galaxies were pulled
into the Vortex not a single one
survived the imminent destruction
brought upon STL and anti-spiral if
there was something you could use as a
metaphor for the word ultimate it would
be the Super Tangen topper Gan
Lagan
coming in strong is the OG the goat and
one of the Heavy Hitters known in anime
Son Goku unlocking Ultra
[Music]
Instinct during the tournament of power
in his fight against the mighty warrior
jiren Goku was pushed into a tight spot
and on the verge of losing even when
Goku was in Super Saiyan blue jiren
easily overpowered him now keep in mind
that before Ultra Instinct was even a
thing Super Saiyan blue was Goku's
strongest form this just shows the huge
gap between jiren and Goku Goku managed
to attain Ultra Instinct through his
unending will to survive the sheer
destructive force of the Spirit Bomb
that nearly killed him it's
aesthetically beautiful to watch Goku
achieve Ultra Instinct for the first
time the change differs from his
previous forms with its distinctive and
arresting visual design which includes
silver hair and an aura this change and
the battles that follow are depicted
with detailed animation and artistic
skill providing the audience with a
visual feast in this state Goku is at
its peak and displays great Feats of
[Music]
Strength moving on this is probably one
of the goofiest displays of ultimate
power in anime Monkey D Luffy's devil
fruit Awakening into the sun god
Nika this shocked a lot of fans because
of its cartoony animation with his
Newfound ability Luffy gains Godlike
abilities by letting him do anything he
can imagine for example he can affect
living beings and inanimate objects and
defy the laws of physics which is an
insanely overpowered ability to have now
that Luffy possesses the Tune Force he's
able to dominate the fight against kaido
even though kaido landed devastating
hits Luffy ended up hitting back
stronger as if he didn't even feel them
without a doubt Luffy's Peak exceeded
everyone's expectations instead of a
badass transformation he basically
turned into a cartoon character which is
actually fitting for him seeing how
Luffy has always been a free-spirited
character
we have another one which is one of my
favorite scenes in all of anime all
might uses the United States of Smash to
defeat All For
One
stay in a last ditch effort to finally
put an end to all for one's evil ways
all might even though he was in a tough
spot with his quir being at his limit
fought with everything he had to defeat
his arch enemy putting everything he had
in that one punch really burned that
seen in all of our brains all might's
determination to protect and save others
despite his physical limitations adds a
profound emotional weight to the move
the phrase United States of Smash itself
evokes a sense of grandeur and power
reflecting the larger than life nature
of the character and his ideals the
animation and artwork for the United
States a smash scene are particularly
well executed the way it's visually
depicted with impactful animation
Dynamic camera angles and dramatic
lighting contributes to its iconic
status in short the moment was just too
perfect with everything that was
happening that scene alone encapsulates
the core themes of heroism and sacrifice
that my hero Academia
[Music]
explores coming up we have the moment
when Adam uses Divine reflection and
copies the fist that surpass
time Adam the father of humanity faces
off against the strongest god in record
of Ragnarok Zeus but even the strongest
god couldn't do anything against Adam's
broken ability the Divine reflection as
a man designed in the image of God Adam
was gifted with the ability to perfectly
replicate any move and technique he lays
his eyes upon including the ones used by
Divine beings this means for every
technique Zeus uses against him Adam can
copy it and fire it back at him even his
strongest attack the fist that surpassed
time was used against him ultimately to
beat Adam Zeus used his final form
Adamas and forced Adam to overheat his
Divine reflection making it a battle of
endurance but even after going blind due
to his immense will to win for his
children Adam kept fighting and passed
away standing ultimately Zeus prevailed
but Adam had earned his begrudging
respect next is melodus using Revenge
counter to defeat
Hendrickson
this is perhaps one of the best moments
in the seven deadly sin Series where
melodus is seen fighting what seems to
be an impossible battle against a
demonized Hendrickson melodus is forced
to use the last trick in his sleeve to
end his fight swiftly the Revenge
counter it works by Motas turning off
his abilities so that he can take an
accumulate damage after melodus has
taken enough damage he charges his Blade
with power and Strikes his enemy with it
this is considered to be melot's
ultimate attack but using Revenge
counter we see just how tough melodus
actually is even though he took all
those attacks headon we can still see
him getting back up and proving while
he's the captain of the legendary seven
deadly sins melot's Revenge counter is a
good example of how an ultimate power
should be executed due to his alignment
with his character the Strategic
elements it introduces it's visually
impressive depiction emotional intensity
narrative significance and its
connection to the series themes it's a
move that proves melot's identity as a
formidable Warrior and a central figure
in the story moving on we get to see
natu uses seven dragon flame Iron Fist
to defeat
analogia imbued with the powers of all
seven Dragon Slayers natu channels their
magic their feelings their hope and
their determination into his fists
finally defeating analogia a
cataclysmically powerful Dragon Slayer
that can take the form of a dragon at
any time because of his overuse of
dragon slayer magic and bathing in the
blood of the Dragons he's killed with
the combined powers of the seven Dragon
Slayers and with the help of Lucy and
other members of the fairy tale guild
they're able to paralyze aalia's body
enabling natu to land a solid hit
infused with everything they got finally
putting an end to analia's reign of
terror what makes this an ultimate
Display of Power is that this perfectly
emulates the story of fairy tale as the
series places strong emphasis on the
bonds of friendship and camaraderie
amongst its characters when natu
achieved his victory against a
formidable foe through the collective
efforts and support of his friends and
allies it reinforced the series call
values and evoked an emotional response
from the
audience burning himself in the list we
have Yamamoto using his Bankai to defeat
UA during the Thousand-Year blood War
Arc for the first time ever Yamamoto
Finally Revealed his bank guy to the
world and displayed the ultimate power
he possesses yamamoto's Bankai has four
forms the first is zanka naachi East
which eliminates anything ruin jaka
touches from existence the second form
is West a defensive ability that covers
Yamamoto and his blades in Flames which
he can choose to be seen or unseen
during activation the surrounding
temperatures exceed 15 million de the
next technique is zankan naachi South a
dreadful ability Yamamoto activates by
inserting his blade into the ground this
resurrects all the dead people that Ryu
Jin jaka has killed however this ability
is meant to destabilize the mental state
of yamamoto's opponents before serving
as a prelude for his final ability zanka
naachi North this ability allows
Yamamoto to spread his Flames to
surrounding areas and to targets he
wishes to harm anything these Flames
touch is reduced to Ash yamamoto's
abilities are proof of how he remained
the captain of goatee 13 despite his
frail appearance for thousands of years
undoubtably despite his tragic demise
Yamamoto remains as part of the
strongest characters in Bleach the depth
of the scene and the visual and sound
effects all contributed to creating one
of the best scenes in anime
history punching through we have
saitama's killer move serious series
serious punch versus boros collapsing
star roaring
Cannon throughout the series syama is
established as an overwhelmingly
overpowered character who defeats his
enemies with a single punch this creates
a stark power disparity between him and
most adversaries boros as the leader of
the Dark Matter thieves is built up as a
formidable opponent who can actually
challenge scy Arma boros is depicted as
an immensely powerful alien warlord with
regenerative abilities immense strength
and a variety of energy based attacks
his durability and regenerative Powers
allow him to withstand scy ARA's initial
punches making him one of the few
characters capable of surviving a blow
from syarma the animation quality
attention to detail and dynamic camera
work contribute to the impact of the
scene the animation brings to life the
intense battle between two Titanic
forces the clashes between their
ultimate moves give us a Peak at how
strong both characters are but
ultimately saarma overpowers boros
aiming his punch at the sky syarma
managed to Blow Away boros's final
attack and split the sea of clouds over
a huge distance using just his sheer
strength making it one of the best
moments when anime characters unleash
their full
power with a more recent occurrence now
we have rimu using bil zebub to consume
[Music]
Clayman despite being an adorable slime
rimu Tempest is a force to be reckoned
with having glonous King b zebub as the
strongest skill in his Arsenal it allows
raru to absorb his targets whole into
his body and gain their properties next
the skill then analyzes what's been
ingested allowing raru to use another
powerful skill mimic with this skill
rimu during wal pgus purged the Demon
Lord Clayman for harming his
subordinates of friends rimu skill B
zeab was strong enough to absorb
clayman's ultimate technique demon
Blaster like it was nothing not only did
he absorb his attack but by using bbub
rimu was able to consume clay and hole
preventing his soul from escaping and
putting an end to his Wicked Ways
showing the other demon Lords that rimu
and his country isn't a person and a
place that anyone should underestimate
there's nothing more dangerous than an
ability that erases the very
[Music]
soul with another fire user we have rang
Goku's ninth form against akaza
[Music]
although this scene in the movie was
anime exclusive and even though rang
Goku lost the battle we've got to admit
that the animation and execution of this
scene aren't something anyone should
ignore only the legendary Ren Goku
family would have the goal to jump
straight to a ninth form after learning
the five established forms of flame
breathing this original form is one of
the most powerful attacks in flame
breathing's repertoire with a
destructive capacity that's breathtaking
to behold despite losing rang Goku
poured every ounce of strength he had in
this one final attack displaying the
power he has and the tenacity of a dying
man with principles to uphold the
animation was pristine and it's welld
deserved to be called his ultimate trump
card a truly worthy entry to this
list fighting his way into the last
three we have SE Yang's 108 torments of
Mankind versus
[Music]
God SE halyang is a character from
another underrated anime called God of
high school and is a proud member of the
six he was the 27th leader of the
national homeless Association prior to
giving that title to Yuma he was an
advanced weapons expert capable of using
losing 108 National Treasures when the
main villain of the story summoned a
being wielding a sword and was revered
by the enemies as God Park mubong was
the first to step up and stop the
creatures Advance later on coh halyang
stepped in and aided mubong by using the
108 torments of mankind which consisted
of various weapons from swords bows and
guns as SEO halang constantly dealt
damage to God's sword he finished the
job by summoning a creature of his own
wearing a mask that bit God's swords and
breaking it in the process not many
characters is are capable of challenging
a God but apparently coh halyang is a
man who bites the sword of God and
celebrates his victory displaying his
Proficiency in using weapons and
strength to overcome extreme
[Music]
adversaries next is when saber alter
uses
Excalibur
[Music]
saber alter is a darker and more
ruthless version of the character
artoria Pendragon who we commonly call
Saber her transformation into saber
altar signifies a departure from her
traditional ideals and a willingness to
wield power at any cost this
transformation sets the stage for a more
intense and Powerful display of her
abilities excaliber is one of the most
iconic and powerful weapons in aruan
Legend and within the Fate series it's
portrayal as has a sword of immense and
holy power aligns with saber alter's
darker nature creating a contrast that
makes her use of Excalibur all the more
impactful in Heaven's feel saber alter's
Excalibur is depicted as an even more
destructive force than usual capable of
unleashing a massive and devastating
attack this version of Excalibur is
often associated with overwhelming power
and an aura of Darkness fitting saber
alter's character it showcases both the
character's inner turmoil and a
willingness to wield immense power for
her goals and last but not least we have
using Venus Dona against
melis
ven anos VOD is The Reincarnation of the
man who was feared as the demon king of
tyranny 2,000 years ago and is the main
protagonist of the anime the misfit of
Demon King Academy his skill venu Dona
is probably the epitome of ultimate
power because the abilities of this
sword are just out of this world venu
Dona can nullify spells and reduce them
to nothing by destroying the order of
the world the abolisher of Reason can
slice a Target without making contact
with it during the fight with melis Aros
summoned venu Dona and quickly showed
his opponent what absolute power looks
like devastated by the fact that none of
his techniques could touch anos melist
couldn't do anything but wait for his
end to come with a sword that
annihilates all laws no one in aros's
verse could ever hope to compete against
him putting him in a class above
everyone
[Music]
else and there you have it the top 20
moments where characters use their
ultimate Powers although there are bound
to be some moments that I've missed let
me know what you think in the comment
section below and remember don't forget
to like share and subscribe once again
thank you rage Shadow Legends for
sponsoring today's video use my link in
the description or scan the QR code and
get started on your raid Journey now see
you in the next one